my gosh
it's far cry 6 time can you believe it
they made another one
no but really i
love
far cry 2
and far cry 3 for
very different reasons like completely
different reasons they're very different
games i tried four and wasn't feeling it
so much i loved blood dragon and then
kind of barely touched five i did play a
little bit of it like enough to grasp
what was happening but i've actually
never finished a far cry since blood
dragon or since three too much of the
same thing maybe i just think i never
felt like any of them had the
the flavor of
far cry 203 far cry 6 is the most
interested i've been in a far cry
since 3 and i'm not sure if it's because
of the setting or how beautiful this
looks
or if it's because i'm a huge fan of the
man who is playing our dictator i just
love him as an actor um but we're gonna
jump into it this is a first play where
i basically play the first hour of
something for you guys in real time
fresh perspective let's jump in to the
first hour of far cry 6. huge thanks
tbsoff for giving me a code i'm very
excited to be able to check it out i
think the game comes out
on the 6th so any minute now really
just have to move myself out of the way
so i can see the screen because i am
playing on my elgato
there we go
first up very good accessibility menu
love to see that we're going to go
straight up here
to new game action mode is the
recommended far cry experience
story mode is experienced with players
who focus on story and explanation we're
going to go action mode
let's do it i'm excited
[Music]
it's not though it's not a real place
don't lie to me already
[Music]
frozen in time 47 years the island
collapsed into poverty until a new
leader was elected with a cure to
rebuild paradise el presidente of yara
anton castillo
that is why i'm here my true yarn
for too long our country was stolen by
politicians
but you elected a vision a cure you see
all of these polls paradise oh my for
reference i'm playing on xbox series
created by our own brilliant scientists
the most effective treatment for cancer
the world has ever seen grown within our
precious tobacco
modified with the purest fertilizer
viviro
is the key to rebranding i didn't know
this
but our thing i was supposed to know
this our enemies will never understand
yara did not elect me to do what's easy
but to do what's right
and so
with renewed focus
i must extend the draft to paradise
through yarns from across our island
chosen to produce enough viviro to heal
the world and save our country
these lucky yarans
will be chosen by random lottery
never a great call but all right
not
you think the draft is only taking true
yaddas is the outcast the poor orphans
like this [ __ ] boy
he's bringing slavery i don't recognize
that
who are you kidding you can't run from
this hang on you ditched us run out to
the jungle with a bunch of ghettos
libertad and you're back here to recruit
for clara garcia's local crusade come on
this is our big goodbye
danny
[ __ ] say something
hmm
see usually i play as a male character
and um i didn't like the choices they
made with the female character in um far
cry 5 like i wish they had just had a
male character instead of trying to do
both
um
but i
i like playing as a woman when i
i like the voice actor i really do like
her voice acting
i think i'm gonna do it we'll see
nice thank you they got my name wrong
she's hot danny you could help libertad
you're trained i would have been korean
military if you weren't such a fuck-off
just come with us lita i
you never [ __ ] listened danny hey
time to go
both waiting drinks in maple
dinner in miami
a bold choice okay
great cool
[ __ ] blackouts too big for a black
off
your [ __ ] package
i wonder if there's a way they could
have delivered the story from what the
[ __ ]
are you getting his name
el presidente
without it being that little expedition
well
no
you're coming
come on danny
she looks kind
just look in real details
i do love like the outpost stealth in
these games and it's good [ __ ]
to hold this oh that's just gonna
the detection meter fills up the
soldiers spot you when full blah blah
blah blah okay cool
i've played a video game before and i
bet you i've just cursed myself like
immediately
next [ __ ] who opens the door is
daniel rojas come on
get out here
oh no
can i just go out this door this okay
well
no you're not no you're not
i don't feel great about what i'm doing
right now i'm warning
but maybe they just really want to go
through that door
and so i'll be fine this way
okay
okay you are making that noise i'm not
resisting
can you be concerned about you can i
take you down no okay
it's okay
i'm actually like feeling very tense
right
it's now nice in the video game
we
like it
welcome to asmr cry everybody we need to
get across that square they're going to
see us i don't think that did not work
that's a lot of soldiers lita so we
thank the sisters
oh gross no i don't want to do that
that's disgusting
can you imagine that
somebody wrote danny that way how
different things had already been going
no thank you oh my god that wasn't so
stinky
give me my valley gold protagonist damn
you want me to run okay
we run it
get in the sword
all right okay cool
how [ __ ] are you taking me quite
impressed by this graphically so far
i don't remember if i felt the same way
about um
watch dogs when i
when i started or not you know i'm going
to go through that way
um yeah watch dogs 3 because i imagine
they like you know i would have had a
lot of overlap these two games
very important
[ __ ]
which i would change
almost there they sound very close
though
good
that boat's not going to wait for us
oh man
well there is a lot of them so i think
we'll be all right
up
oh i thought that she was gonna like do
an extreme taco
i would have been sick
and stuff too
hey don't don't mind me
sorry i wasn't here like i said i'm
super sorry oh no i have a health bar
now
[Music]
that's where it came from
oh zipline ah ladder
one of the two
on castillo's [ __ ] castle
[Music]
are they just hunting for everybody
right now or is it specific like is it
just people who are out to type
curfews where the [ __ ] are the police
they're just letting the military kill
us
yeah i can't tell if it's because of the
way that i'm playing
or if there are
frame rate problems because i'm playing
through an elgato way to play
keep moving
we're almost there is she still with us
i haven't seen leader in years
remember
you'll have to let me on
yeah i don't want to misrepresent the
game in case it is just the fact that
i'm what the hell i'm gonna do with this
playing correctly
that might not have the right settings
he gave up his ticket
for his family
[ __ ]
alejo's not going anywhere anymore
come on my god
let them on
good man
get out of boxing
[Music]
don't worry about it
here
that's all i've got
this isn't right bunny
we should be fighting not running to the
young keys alejo gave you a [ __ ] gift
lyda we survived same as the orphanage
same as the academy
right on time
dramatic timing no no it comes at you
fast
this boat did not seem that big but
maybe i just don't have concept of bugs
who knows
oh no
a rich person
oh it's him wow okay
i didn't expect that
before
he was el presidente me papa love to
fish
we would go out on a boat just like this
and we would catch the fish
and then
release them he would say it's not
always a ball your
the challenge
except when he caught a big fat juicy
marlins
that i barely played
to let that fish go
no you have voices
on your sword
[Applause]
oh spicy i have caught a very big fish
today
have a night diego
diego
no way
i didn't expect that i have gotten
now it's time to bring you home
i don't want this anymore papa we have
no choice
let them go
they can work make viviro truth
or lies
truth
they could be good workers
they could help rebuild paradise
but if you wanted them to live you would
have never set foot on his [ __ ] boat
13 years old
and diego has such
compassion
for his people
these things what somebody does
we will
catch
a release
what does that mean does that mean
murder because it didn't sound like
murder i feel like you should have been
a little bit more specific about what
that meant i would like to know
you do not love to see it
so what are we gonna get out and like
swim somewhere
it's gonna be sharks
right
it's wild how many ubisoft studios
there are and how many people work at
ubisoft and make all this stuff it's
such a big talk on my legs
[ __ ] little this is all my fault my
phone
forget it
my phone
this is the beach study i gotta
put this on the gram
what
she's hiding here
lara
libertad
julio
[ __ ]
where are you
take my phone
follow the code like when we were kids
stop it dude that's not working did i
miss part of that
just wait i'll find hell no
you give her this
clara will help you
thank you
you're the lucky one danny
you're the lucky one
we're off to a rough start here
it's not looking great for danny
all right i like that for us
[Music]
it's a good opening very dramatic
okay
let me move myself up a little bit so
many dead there we go
i should look for supplies and get the
[ __ ] out of here
all right can we go for a swim
i really should check the beach for
supply
just wanted to know turns out you can i
don't know why i would have expected any
different just i just like to make sure
pretty looking water too i always judge
video games on water okay that's not
great
um
yeah the waves it's hard to do it's hard
to do
pistol is empty okay i take it back
need to find that camp oh that's some
nice lens flare oh wow that was
aggressive
how the [ __ ] is this still working i
agree the markings must be the code lita
was talking about
okay
that's going to be just between here
then right
surely
yeah the whole controller vibrated i
wonder what that feels like on a jewel
sense i'm playing on um
an xbox
um elite
series one
i don't remember
looks like i followed the blue to
liberta
okay
i don't feel like it's at all safe oh
shooting
better stay quiet yeah
we're now stealing it's actually going
to be
visually impressed it's not perfect but
all rotten on the inside
why you died that was nice now i'm going
to call this in oh you pick up ammo by
walking you're going to be slowly eaten
all right well good day are you all
right mate i'm not the only one looking
for bladder
okay
hell yeah pesos
i'm gonna kill you two
pants how to equip pant
all right
hell yeah
new pants does it actually do anything
different
well i'm undoing the set
i actually um
i think i have a like a
costume set that that i got with the
game but i don't think i can equip it
until a little bit later they gave me a
blood dragon one pretty sure which is
neat
and now i'm talking to myself yeah she
sounds like dutch
i have a plan
we're gonna go to haiti
i can't do a dutch accent it doesn't
[ __ ]
okay
been a while since i used one of these
cool
um
okay
done this in person and it is actually
very fun ladder doesn't want visitors
okay
gonna show your face before you shoot me
oh he cute i'm danny
a friend of lita
silencio
hot
i love that
you are the only survivor
hell of an intro nobody else got that
all right clara answer me
i said
are you the only survivor
see that i know okay
they don't know their risks
that's all you have to say you're here
that's what matters
just a second hermana i'm getting the
hell out of yara
well you're in my camp i need a place to
stay a few days
libertas no charity hermana
lita said you'd help
lita also said you weren't a [ __ ]
you deserve that one i'm with them
you're an orphan see
funny how friends can be closer than
family
remember danny
castillo has kept you an orphan
[Music]
why do you want to run
i watch castillo order a whole boat of
our people shot to death
get as far away as you can from that
psychopath
all of you
when tyranny is law revolution is order
quoting bolivar won't save you it's
pedro albiso gonna save yara with
library cards
i have a list nice node
free elections free expression free the
outcasts a yara free of castiles simple
simple
what 300 000 troops i count six burnt
out guerrillas and you
with a bullet to the leg
you don't believe me
i'll show you
we launched an attack from our base to
this island was a basic operation
here tobacco plantation snatched some
fuel and go home
but castillo's forces were waiting
implications of the you need to get back
to your base yes but this is surrounded
by a blocker
we don't have boats we don't have much
gear and we are not leaving until that
viviro plantation goes up in smoke okay
but we are curious we know this land
inside out you're already familiar with
argeria paths
they were built by the legends in 67
they're spread like a web across all of
yara now they're ours
guerrilla pastor go to ambush soldados
or to hide if the army is on your back
they have caches that will help you
survive
and all of this is legit this map is old
as hell
made for tourists yeah it's out of date
but you got the regions municipalities
and landmarks
tourists
to get us a boat and you need to go find
me juan cortes
who someone who can make one guerrilla
fight like a thousand
hmm
cool
you know i'm not a giddy yeah right
i'll give you food a bed even a goddamn
boat to sail to the yankees but it's
gonna cost you bullets and blood
you can shoot so shoot
settle in
and let me know when you want to pay
your rent
that was surprisingly easy
suspiciously easy she's going to betray
me
let's have a look
around i'm assuming i go to multiple
islands like um like in previous games
as well
what do you mean i don't have a million
things to loot i don't believe you
this doesn't make sense there has to be
it's a video game
all of this is lootable i should be able
to pick up every single one of these
bottles
oh you got is that
i was going to say mayonnaise but now
it's got an orange on it so i'm not sure
is that the whitest thing i've ever said
should i know what that is
because i do not
all i know is mayonnaise you know
love to steal from my new friends oh
joycey
awesome
cool
seems like a more fitting coal even
though i like that baseball team
different enemy types huh oh there's
pyro's
they'll be tanks all right i'm ready
that's cool
this actually so far plays a lot like
the first crisis
um okay let's head back up shelby
what is up
i attacked this archipelago with a man
named juan cortes he helped me build
libertad from the dirt
juan's a spymaster from the pre-castillo
days
can build an icbm from a goddamn ice
cube tray
pulled off ops for espinosa the kgb then
flipped to the cia and mossad for fun
juan is my mentor i just feel like
somebody should be made
alcoholic
she went south he was so
embarrassed out of my camp
because
would love nothing more than to capture
a double agent like cortes
i need him back with neighbor dad danny
he's done with us but you're a fresh
face
take this earpiece juan made them for
comms then head to the village okay if i
were to go and alcohol check the bar
first
cool get down to that village and bring
me cortes
i hope for your sake is sober well
sunrise i think just happened
that doesn't necessarily fare well
okay
well that's all i have right now i'm
sure this will get more extensive that's
a neat looking ui
all right
find one get xp
run down side of mountain
shall we
it sure does feel like far cry i'll tell
you that much i was hoping i'd be able
to jump down there
is that an animal
danny how's the earpiece can you hear me
okay loud and clear yes ma'am the spy
sheet works clara i'll give you that
vienne
keep your gun holstered if you want to
stay out of trouble especially in areas
with a lot of soldados see i got it a
smart area picks their battles
not seeing anybody worth fighting just
yet oh okay
what's your weapon is lb
approaching soldiers too closely we'll
draw
the on halls with rt cool
it'll be hole and then weapon wheel got
it okay
got it got it got it
oh that's pretty
well isn't that nice
oh okay
so i should assume
ammonia is hostile or just that i can
make it hostile if i
get all up in a soldier too fast
okay no weapons allowed gotcha
oh red zone
i see i see do i need to avoid that
that's nice
yeah maybe it's just that building
don't mind me just swimming up to meet
my friend in a bar totally normal stuff
totally normal
that looks like a one
i think we saw this in the trailer that
extended gameplay reveal
[Music]
today we're drinking the worst [ __ ]
cantina in yara or is in colombia
chechnya
leave the bottle let's work for you
he seems
so bad but planning to own so that is
how i take it
a guerrillas revolution never ends
always another war another cantina
another ugly bartender
juan cortese
what do you think gave it away weapon
this isn't a [ __ ]
i love him
see
i learned long ago never to doubt her
you will too
hey
i know you
don't think so
yeah i know you it's like i'm looking at
a mirror weapon what are you talking
about those eyes
you got a taste
you convince yourself you're a hero but
you wake up at yonki just like juan
cortes
this is a [ __ ] waste of time can you
whistle
what
nah you can't listen
i like him
[Music]
oh my god a trained alligator assuming
that's an alligator not a crocodile
i have to get a look at his nose
the world's more dead anyway
[Music]
i love it
what the [ __ ] say
boy say love with you
that's an alligator and i ruined the
only copy of he's chunky i'm sure of it
once again
we have outstayed our welcome
all right i feel like this is what i
thought
this game would do um which is like have
it be a mix of like um
[ __ ] right it's like old pink
i don't remember which one it is um
it's like a little bit silly and there
are some creative weapons but it doesn't
go all out on the silliness you know
you better not touch my alligator
[ __ ]
no no not ever
they are bad guys right yeah okay oh
interesting
i love it
can i have him yes you see mine now also
there was that little dog i forgot about
has like progressively automated things
more and more which is great for um
accessibility for a bunch of reasons
like
potentially
people with one hand can play this game
um
but i don't know if i like the
automation like do you prefer to be able
to walk over a soldier maybe you can
toggle it too um or do like the full red
dead two animation where you flip them
and everything like i don't know
i don't know i guess over time it gets
boring who wants to be your friend
or maybe he just needs to take a dump i
love him where is he only one way to
find out
where where do you go
oh my god
amigos
oh my god i love you so much they have
unique abilities
because i didn't play much of uh five i
didn't get a lot with the with the dog
whatever his name was
guapo's kin never went extinct he
passively recovers health to keep
fighting and self-revives after being
down in combat body regulation cornered
beast and reptiles
that's him i think
what no it's chorizo it's chorizo oh my
gosh
is that like a big cat
wow
little jackpot come on let's go we got
business
oh my god
i still good waffle
[Laughter]
oh sorry all my achievements gonna be
very aggressive
oh my god oh my god this is the content
you're all here for i imagine danny
so clara says you're a legend xkgb xcia
i got more [ __ ] x's than your porn
search history
some men
they break eggs not that many exes but
one pulled up
new plants
plan is to go back to clara's camp
where the hell are we going now
dude i'll go wherever you want me to as
long as i get to hang out with this dude
whatever amigo wants
see that smoke see that's that means the
watchtower just got a supply drop with
some of the rarest materials you're
going to teach me how to ubisoft you are
going to go get it yes now you want me
to steal [ __ ] for you always a good
you know
i don't know that we want to attack them
just yet
are they going to notice
the alligator there also is there a tag
oops
oh you just have to zoom in okay
is that el presidente complaining about
clara she's that cool
are you upset about the crocodile
get him
get him
you're gonna hurt him
i just want to know what he can do you
know what i'm saying
dude get
him and nobody helped why am i
all right
i feel like i'm gonna have to kill you
now
they would have seen the bullets but
i used to love doing these with um
but i don't have any styling oh i didn't
realize that
after that outline um yeah i don't have
any silence yet also this is probably
pretty easy right i probably can just
sort of shoot everybody
oh they're all highlighted
oh no the loot is highlighted i see i
see i see okay
this could be useful
get the supply drop
that was very easy
doesn't seem fundamentally different to
previous games i'm alright with it
though
they're always fun
what the hell are you going to do with
this always
people have said this proudly for
generations
but remember
this is all the colonizers see
a jewel an object one they can worship
for one
i take ownership of this
found all your [ __ ] juan
that's what i've been saying
wait i should check this new
gun
interesting
ah we're just gonna
they're both equipped because they're
working well
oh it did have bows in there huh
yeah
i look forward to it
very good possessing
forgetting the name of the [ __ ] was it
are
is the the very pink one with the
ridiculous weapons it was fun though or
is this obviously more grounded but like
what he's holding looks ridiculous
what the quan is holding looks very
one-of-a-kind okay we got more than
enough let's get the [ __ ] out of here
all right dog let's roll
so what's with all this junk pretty
short hike you building something
patience danny
rule number eight hey guerrilla knows
how to wait
like a spider or a serial killer
so how did you get to this god for a
second hell horn i was on our refugee
ship we didn't get far yeah yeah and i
came here in a chopper in our baby
invasion saturn shot straight out of the
goddamn sky no he sounded sarcastic
orphanage
got it and the military
i'm nogeria
just helping clara out until she gets me
off this island rule 20.
once again
always again are you saying that i am
off with that
too late
the horse is out of the barn and now the
[ __ ] cocaine is all over the kids
daddy damn there is no other option wow
okay
of course
and you think americans want your yarn
blood
the american dream is for americans
you don't quit do you he's probably not
wrong about that
if you two are so close
why is he following me he's guava goes
with those who need him most
like those therapy that has a laser
sight on it what is that guys
oh my god yeah
not sure i'm there yet you got time no i
i do
chopper was shut down in the invasion
can you fix it so i can fly you to the
yankees
no i it's grounded
but i'm working on it patience
now it's time for one cortes to show you
how to make something out of nothing i
like how quickly they introduced me to
this character and that like i feel like
i know him like he doesn't feel like a
stranger immediately
which is pretty neat
having a great time go eat whatever you
like
manzanas
it's also doing this really interesting
thing when i'm when i'm sprinting at
stopping me from it because of the
conversation also sorry i keep moving
i've been sitting in this chef too long
butt hurts
how many others
the legend returns the legend needs to
piss heffa
who's she
she was a journalist who they're called
anton fasista now she's an outcast a
slave for his paradise and she's not the
only one danny
i am
resolver isn't making
do with what you have it's inflicting
chaos with everything you got
oh that's not a real quote that's just
from juan
okay
time you learn about wrestler danny i
was six when i rigged my first bike with
a chainsaw motor
the blockade means i have to resolve it
every day juan ah that's survival for a
guerrilla resource and just making do
with what you have
it's inflicting chaos
they're gonna teach me this straight
away huh
all right
keep talking
weapon is the workbench go ahead danny
let's take a crack at those weapons no
offense but your battle rifle is a
little basic rule number nine always use
the right tool for the right job
sometimes i lie awake at night asking
myself juan excellent danny now you can
pop enemy flesh like a ripe watermelon
does heavy damaging is on almost let's
look at your other rifle let's say your
target remember to wear their helmet and
best today you're gonna need some
armor-piercing rounds these rounds fly
straight and through and go nice now
you've got yours
high velocity war crimes let's look at
your attachments time to make your very
first suppressor this will turn a bang
into a bang
at the cost of some range
okay
see how easy that was now you can
silently headshot your enemies like a
real [ __ ] beautiful the world bench
is your friend danny
a friend with benefits nice cozy with it
that does seem pretty simple but i don't
feel like i have anything yet so
making [ __ ] as addictive with that
workbench you can build a new yada
you're not one of us
cool
quest one completed
i have to keep moving
resolve the weapons to
improve and customize my weapons using
materials steal
materials from military supply drops on
animals okay pretty standard far cry
stuff i understand
all righty
you keep rolling danny
one
want to steal honey i've got big plans
for you but first i need you to get a
thing for me
now i hear you ask one what is this
thing you need truth all you need to
know is don't try to eat it talk to
it is i gotta watch that but one i hear
you ask where is this thing you need
head for the radio tower and follow the
trail north you always gotta get your
radio showers in there easy are smoking
a cigar on sunday somebody
is the
alligator gonna gonna join
music's nice it's all very peaceful
right now
and i don't know if this is the right
way to go it feels like it is
oh there's a horse over there
what
hello are you
writable
all right
okay red dead redemption a horse in
space oh my god this feels really weird
at first
i do not ever do this in red dead too
okay
this is fun i'm having a good time
[Music]
hold up
come on
i wonder what pepper set stops right now
i just actually want to be doing this
not the whole
gorilla pot the the gorilla warfare part
less interested trying to escape from my
life
less interested
ride a horse in the sun
sounds great
take out all the soldiers and destroy
the f d bible to capture the checkpoint
okay that's more like your
outposts
whoa is there going to be one here
ah
[Music]
how do i find a map do i want to go
through this
realistically it wants me to right
come on
i'm trying to dismantle here leave this
area now okay leaving
hey hey what did i just tell you oh you
don't know
[Music]
okay didn't one of my guns have
i don't know which one it was
which one did i put the muzzle on
this one
right
okay that's the ms-16
ms-16
see what we want to do
just today
checkpoint two of them got to behave
okay watch yourself danny
that is a risk
that is a risk
i don't feel good about it
nobody's there it's fine nobody's
stressed about anything
what if i could just take you out
find them
okay they're not getting away
it may have been bad
no
okay i might just be fine here though
grenade's not my favorite but
where did she go
unclear
where are you up here
this doesn't do as much damage as i
thought not by a long shot is it just
happened
it is oh okay
okay i was playing that very dumb that
was not that hot
um you want me to shoot it
i felt like a waste of ammo but all
right
okay we now own this
congrats
took out two people
real estate
it's a hot market bet this place has a
stash room
it does
but how to enter
with the key great cool yep
love that all right
one that checkpoint is dude
memorandum anti-vandalism initiatives
note that any dangerous material should
be stored at fort quito without
attracting the attention to the public
also central to our mission here is the
message that we are here for the people
to have this idea home we have an
officially approved billboard has been
placed at every checkpoint you'll notice
that gorillas have attempted to destroy
them to send a counter propaganda
message
we will not stand for terrorist
vandalism harsh
all right some old people great love
that i love um low poly old people
really
really captures the heart of it all
okay
beautiful though
can i use this map who done that
get out of my hood
your horse can stay who are you
you're good okay
not super worried about any of you
oh do you need help
i'm sorry that this happened
cool
all right
on we go come with me alligator easy now
oh my god i'm so sorry
oh my bad bring this horse to a horse
pick-up point you will then be able to
call it from any come on
that's why there are horses everywhere
neat
okay
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
okay
ah a climbable tower
innovator
that was pretty sick fun i may have
found the tower but it was stopped
and follow it to my contact
see i'm on my way okay
can i have this openable it is not
um where do you want me to go
this way
i thought i would have to climb that
disbelief
i like my shoes
oh that's cool
very nice
this is pretty too
hello contact you're in the right place
oh i'm glad you're my name is raisa and
i'm going to be helping you steal [ __ ]
from castillo today nice are you going
to tell me what i'm stealing depleted
uranium ferdon i thought you just said
uranium you heard me look all i know is
i burned my last contact in the army
tracking it down for juan ux military
isn't everybody okay
just show me where it is first you take
this parachute trust me it can save your
life what's that now i'll take you to
the old spanish fort
okay
parachutes yep
far cry sure is happening
we feel good about it
or volunteer
conscript my number came up so i did my
time
yo
volunteer
all i wanted to be was a soldier you
know where the uniform served my country
found out the only kind of soldier
castillo wants is a blind fascist
addicted to his every word
so now you're a traitor yeah and i'm not
the only one there's a guard posted at
the watchtower ahead he's going to let
us use it to scout out the fort he can
also give us useful info what does he
want from us
the island feels huge right now
so keep your gun what's the problem
nothing sorry my butt hurts
let me holster my gun okay stay close
one not to get his ass shot so keep your
gun holstered or he'll open fire
two a little bribe to these double
agents will get us military intel
right you don't know if i don't know
what do you have anything basil's ready
oh i guess i do okay
arriving double agents
some soldiers are fnd double agents and
have valuable intel holds your weapon
before
approaching them okay
i can do that they've already done it
i think i do i feel like i pick some up
in some
crates
maybe like a bin
what can you tell me okay check this out
here's where you can find some weapons
around here i appreciate it
sure what is why are you doing right
to do
i don't want to be around that's cool
and then is this where you want me to go
oh no
okay
everyone's got their prize not every
soldier is a fanatic some are just
trying to feed their families just
remember to put the guns away before you
approach them
okay
you want to stop and have a cigarette is
that what's happening here
all right
i guess what was happening okay
noted you do you fam
some of this has to be lootable
surely it feels so weird
what just
something something just like lifted me
high for a second
use your phone to scout out enemy
soldiers and see their weaknesses
i bet juan's already giving you his
right tool for the right job talk
um i don't know how to pull it out
up use your phone camera to scout
location attack soldiers that makes
sense or reveal their weaknesses
use the wife bench to build and instill
different movie weapons interesting
i want you to like change things on the
fly
okay
there's the officer in charge alvarez
has the key to the armory careful this
feels very he's higher right a recent
assassin
that means he's better trained quicker
with the trigger and a tough
[ __ ]
surely does my mess
i don't bite for a second
this fort is the most protected base on
the island oh these soldiers have been
issued with body armor and helmets
nothing armor piecing rounds can't
handle use the workbench if you need to
craft some and then go
i think i'm probably okay
but
because i feel like
well i could do that anyway as well
right
i know the suppressor
will that do much fast
okay cool
ammo socket we want the armor piercing
rounds
on both of them right
that's done
and then i think you already have
all my facing rounds
cool
okay
that's like uranium that
all right
what's that parachute i gave you could
come in handy here just don't drop into
the middle of the phone okay
um we're in an hour though so
technically i have to stop here this is
uh
definitely like feels like i've just
touched the beginning like i really feel
like i barely even
you know started and i don't want to
stop playing right now so it's like i'm
definitely into it um certainly feels
like far cry i like the characters so
far very into the villain like i said i
will play more of it um
it's a sucky time to have to stop but i
said i'd only play an hour i don't ever
want to like spoil people beyond that
that first hour of impressions is kind
of the point so
let's be let's notice this [ __ ] those
arseholes still haven't fixed the cave
2
is still lightly guarded it's like they
think gorillas can't swim interesting
the approach to the power station is
still wide open it's a [ __ ]
invitation the uranium is locked up in
the armory captain elmarez
always has the key and i bet my life the
other one's still in his office right
out of the [ __ ] manuals like they
want to be portrayed
interesting yeah well i will do this but
uh
not in front of all of you because the
time just stopped me from it um
but yeah am i playing somewhere in the
game on the stream
on twitch.tv
charlotte's at some point i can't even
say my own name but otherwise thank you
all for watching i hope you enjoyed the
first hour of far cry 6.
i will for sure play more of it not
blown away not not feeling like anything
is super different um but i'm into it so
we'll take it bye